la parole à Monsieur Jean-Noël Cardot
pour les questions numéro 68 qui vous
est adressé vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue oui monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais attirer votre attention sur
les problèmes posés à l'organisation des
services départementaux de transport
colère suite au possible retour à une
semaine de 4 jours et demi et à
l'allongement de deux semaines de
l'année scolaire pour les classes de
primaire et de maternelle ce n'est pas
tant des rythmes scolaires qu'il s'agit
mais plutôt des répercussions de cette
mesure sur les budgets des conseils
généraux en effet les transports
scolaires constituent une contrainte
technique essentielle en province et
notamment en milieu rural or pour le
Loiret leur coût pour les maternelles et
les primaires pourraient augmenter de
près 32%, c'est une demi-journée est
ajoutée à la semaine et si l'année
scolaire est allongée en effet le coût
en transport scolaire d'une demi-journée
d'enseignement en plus chaque semaine
reviendra 375
000 euros par an et deux semaines de
cours en plus sur l'année coûteront
100.000 euros le budget de département
en matière de transport scolaire
passerait donc de 1 million et demi
d'euros à près de 2 millions d'euros à
la charge du conseil général
vous le comprendrez qu'il s'agit de
Somme conséquentes pour un budget
départemental sous tension j'ajoute que
pas plus tard que samedi dernier votre
collègue Anne-Marie Escoffier
anciennement de notre assemblée est venu
présider dans mon département
l'assemblée générale des mers ruraux et
précisément le président de cette
association l'interpellé sur ce problème
parce que je soulève celui des
transports scolaires mais les maires de
petites communes rurales devront devront
réorganiser les garderies périscolaires
avec une charge aussi non négligeable
sur des budgets qui eux aussi sont très
contraints je vous demande donc monsieur
le ministre si vous pensez conduire une
concertation large et approfondie avec
tous les acteurs concernés et en
particulier les collectivités locales et
quelles mesures pourrait être proposées
pour aider les départements si le
changement des rythmes scolaires se
confirmait
merci mon chers collègues la parole à
Monsieur Vincent payant ministre de
l'éducation nationale
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
la refondation de l'école et la
concertation qu'il accompagne depuis le
début juillet sont la traduction vous le
savez de l'engagement du président de la
République de faire de la jeunesse et de
colle en son cœur la priorité du
quinquennat au cœur de cette
concertation un groupe de travail s'est
mis en place sur la question des rythmes
scolaires et de l'articulation entre le
temps scolaire le temps éducatif
pourquoi parce que cette consultation
avait d'ailleurs déjà été menée par le
ministère précédent et les
parlementaires y avait été associés tout
le monde convient que les rythmes
scolaires en France ne sont pas
favorables à l'épanouissement des
enfants mais en même temps à
l'acquisition des connaissances trop peu
de journée 144 par an des journées sur
et une année déséquilibrée ce constat a
été partagé au-delà des clivages
traditionnels des familles politiques et
a permis dans le fond un consensus nous
considérons donc que dans l'intérêt des
élèves il serait souhaitable que nous
puissions modifier un certain nombre de
ces paramètres il y a ce que vous
évoquez la journée
de classe qui entraînerait évidemment
qui devrait être alléger mais
entraînerait une nouvelle organisation
entre le temps assumé par l'Éducation
nationale et celui assumé par les
collectivités locales il y a l'année
aucune décision n'a été prise vous
évoquait deux semaines de plus
c'est-à-dire un passage de 36 à 38
semaines parfois en réalité nous savons
même que les 36 semaines ne sont pas
faites et là encore il y a un
déséquilibre et vous évoquez la semaine
avec la journée du mercredi matin qui
serait celle qui serait envisagé
c'est-à-dire un retour ce qui existait
avant 2008 nous serons dans quelques
temps quels sont les préconisations de
la concertation je tiens à vous indiquer
que les collectivités territoriales sont
pleinement associées à la concertation
sur les rythmes scolaires elles sont
présentes dans les groupes de travail à
travers leurs associations
représentatives et j'ai moi-même reçu à
peu près l'ensemble des associations
donc l'Association des maires de France
l'Assemblée des Départements
l'Association des régions de France mais
aussi les associations qui dans le fond
représente des mers qui peuvent éprouver
des difficultés particulières sur ces
sujets l'Association des Maires des
grandes villes l'Association des Maires
Ruraux avec lesquels nous avons
travaillé l'Association nationale des
élus de la montagne ou l'Association
nationale des élus du littoral les élus
locaux ont donc exprimer pleinement leur
préoccupations nous y sommes sensibles
car nous sommes convaincus qu'aucune
grande réforme de l'école peut se faire
contre les élèves contre les parents a
fortiori contre les collectivités
locales dont je dis souvent je l'avais
dit au Sénat 1er à ma première audition
elles sont celles qui investissent le
plus aujourd'hui en progression sur
l'école et donc nous avons absolument
besoin d'aide de ce point de vue les
discussions ont lieu vous évoquez le
département du Loiret qui est le vôtre
et les calculs que vous avez pu faire il
y a une augmentation que vous estimez à
32%, d'autres départements se sont
lancés dans les mêmes calculs par
anticipation sans mettre nécessairement
les 36 ou les 38 semaines mais souvent
sur la journée de quatre jours et demi
et arrive je pense par exemple au
département du Rhône un des chiffres
très différents des vôtres puisque par
exemple pour le département du Rhône
mais il a une configuration différente
nous sommes simplement à 1% du budget
j'ai demandé une étude extrêmement
précise pour voir la diversité des
situations car nous ne ferons pas une
réforme des rythmes scolaires qui
aggraveraient les inégalités
territoriales ou sociales notre objectif
est exactement le contraire
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Noël Cardou pour répondre à
Monsieur le Ministre d'éducation
nationale mais merci monsieur le
ministre de cette exposé mon propos
n'était pas du tout de mettre en cause
votre projet de modification des rythmes
scolaires et des consultations que vous
avez effectuées auprès de l'ensemble des
collectivités comme vous le dites il y a
des pour il y a des contre quel que soit
leur tendance politique et c'était pas
du tout mon intervention c'était la
conséquence sur le budget du département
et je crois que très récemment
l'Assemblée des départements de France
est réunis son président est un de vos
proches amis et il a attiré l'attention
du gouvernement sur les charges qui
pesaient sur les collectivités en
particulier et en matière de couverture
d'appât et de RSA pour les départements
donc ce qui est à craindre si les
chiffres que j'ai annoncé sont confirmés
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a des
différences dans l'organisation des
transports scolaires suivant les
départements et bien que de plus en plus
de département
seront conduits à répercuter totalement
ou partiellement le coût de ces
transports scolaires sur les familles
nous y sommes passés l'année dernière
dans Loiret au cerbes dans des
proportions bien modestes puisque nous
répercutons 10% du coût total des
transports scooter scolaires sur les
familles d'autres départements étaient
passés sur ce système avant nous et je
citerai sans vouloir faire de mauvaise
esprit celui de la Corrèze et donc je
crains et que si nous avons des charges
considérables qui résulte de cette
modification et bien nous répercuterons
encore un peu plus sur les familles
secouent et qu'évidemment un certain
moment cela risque de créer des
problèmes donc voilà je tenais à tirer
votre attention et je souhaiterais donc
vous associer pleinement encore plus la
déesse assez négociation